fast jede nacht knallte es in
deutschland gangster überfallen keine
banken mehr sie jagen einfach die
geldautomaten in die luft besonders
stark betroffen sind die grenzregionen
zu den niederlanden in nordrhein
westfalen und niedersachsen allein in
nrw sind in den ersten sechs monaten
dieses jahres
105 geldautomaten gesprengt worden
schaden mehr als zehn millionen euro
die täter fliehen meistens in hoch
motorisierten autos rasen mit tempo 300
richtung niederlande unsere reporter
sebastian prengel andré schieck osi und
michael schinkel waren den gangstern auf
der spur und haben dabei auch ein
internationales fahndungs team begleitet
sie kommen mitten in der nacht sie sind
brutal und skrupellos und sie nehmen in
kauf dass menschen sterben damit sie an
ihre beute kommt blitzschnell bringen
die gangster sprengladungen an
geldautomaten an dann zerreißen heftige
explosionen die nächtliche ruhe jede
nacht fliegt irgendwo in deutschland ein
geldautomat in die luft und es werden
immer mehr die gläser rappelt das bild
hat gezittert der boden unter meinen
füßen er hat gezittert ich kriege immer
die worte mit sei vorsichtig auf der
arbeit
um heil wieder nach hause ich will
möglichst alle erwischen
tatort castrop rauxel um ein uhr nachts
werden anwohner von einer lauten
detonation aus dem schlaf gerissen drei
gangster haben hier die
sparkassenfiliale in die luft gejagt das
gebäude in dem im betreuten wohnen auch
bettlägerige menschen leben ist schwer
zerstört doch darauf nehmen die täter
keine rücksicht sie hinterlassen ein
feld der verwüstung allein der schaden
am haus beträgt rund 350.000 euro bis
die sparkassenfiliale wieder öffnen kann
werden monate vergehen wir sehen hier
die wucht der zerstörung die
sparkassenfiliale ist ein totalschaden
hier haben geldautomaten sprenger mit
fest sprengstoff gearbeitet und die
sprengwirkung dies für diese gangster
unberechenbar wir sehen dass es ist das
reinste chaos was sie hinterlassen haben
das ist einmal der geldautomat gewesen
und darum herum hat es die druckwelle in
der ganzen filiale ausgebreitet überall
auf dem boden verteilt sind
trümmerschutt und splitter und das zeigt
natürlich wie skrupellos diese täter
vorgehen die haben nämlich nur ein
einziges ziel und das ist mit allen
mitteln an das geld in den automaten zu
kommen
dass die täter immer brutaler werden
erkennt jetzt auch die politik
nrw-innenminister herbert reul macht das
problem zur chefsache
wenn man geldautomaten sprengen will
dann braucht man drei dinge
erstens man muss ausgesprochen
kaltblütig seien diese täter kennen
keine skrupel sie fahren in dem wissen
dass sie jeden meter jemanden aus dem
leben reißen können zweitens
brauchen sie natürlich die entsprechende
ausrüstung
die sie drittens in den kofferraum eines
richtig schnellen autos laden die dritte
veränderung heute hat die polizei es mit
waghalsigen und halsbrecherischen flucht
fahrten zu tun und auf diese veränderten
vorgehen und auf die neue brutalität
müssen wir reagieren wir begeben uns auf
die spur der automaten springer sie sind
so schnell weg wie sie gekommen sind
flüchten in den meisten fällen mit
hochmotorisierten fahrzeugen über die
grenze in die niederlande ihre beute im
jahr 2020 17 millionen euro das macht im
schnitt pro sprengung und 50.000 euro an
den fahndungsmaßnahmen im deutsch
niederländischen grenzgebiet ist auch
das grenzüberschreitende polizeiteam das
gpt beteiligt im zivilwagen sitzen
deutsche und niederländische beamte der
vorteil rasen die panzerknacker auf der
flucht über die grenze ist die
verfolgungsjagd nicht vorbei es ändert
sich nur die zuständigkeit innerhalb des
teams trotzdem gegen die rücksichtslosen
verbrecher haben die beamten kaum eine
chance mit sprengstoff und
benzinkanistern im fluchtwagen sind die
gangster nicht zu stoppen ohne
menschenleben zu riskieren
verfolgungsjagten auf der autobahn
werden schnell zum himmelfahrtskommando
erst kann lebensgefährlich sein wenn man
die falsche einschätzung macht aber gut
wir sind ja profis - man hat natürlich
auch mit dass übrigen verkehr zu tun was
auch ausbremst also dranbleiben auf eine
leere autobahn es
ist fast unmöglich da muss man schon mit
anderen mitteln arbeiten wie
hubschrauber wir sind natürlich nicht
alleine und arbeiten eng zusammen mit
anderen teams mit anderer polizisten in
deutschland in holland man muss damit
rechnen dass solche hohe
geschwindigkeiten dass man tatsächlich
noch nach eine sprengung
entweder explosiven dem fahrzeug hat
oder auch benzin
und dass das macht die einschätzung auch
sehr schwierig um sein fahrzeug zu
stoppen während der fahrt mit drei und
km/h es ist auch fast unmöglich um so in
ein fahrzeug wirklich stoppen zu bringen
das ist fast unmöglich skrupellos rasen
die springer auf der flucht mit 300
stundenkilometern über die autobahn
die ihre fahrzeuge sind ausgerüstet wie
im actionfilm die airbags sind
ausgeschaltet damit sie sich notfalls
den weg frei räumen können nachts
schalten sie auf der autobahn bei
vollgas das licht aus vasen mit
nachtsichtgeräten durch die dunkelheit
sie können funksignale der polizei orten
und mit german die telekommunikation
stören und man muss wissen bei
geschwindigkeiten um 300 kilometer pro
stunde hängen die springer sogar die
polizeihubschrauber ab die gangster
fahren schneller als die polizei fliegen
kann der so halsbrecherisch über
öffentliche straßen rad muss das
trainieren fluchtwagenfahrer werden aber
nicht im straßenverkehr ausgebildet
sondern wie hier in zandvoort
professionell auf formel 1 rennstrecken
geschult nicht weit weg von der heimat
der gangster viele täter wurden im raum
utrecht rotterdam und amsterdam
das lka nrw schätzt den kreis der
schwerverbrecher auf 500 bis 700
personen
hier leben die automaten springer von
hier aus sorge sie in deutschland für
angst und schrecken nach offiziellen
zahlen sollen eben zwei drittel der
täter einen migrationshintergrund haben
und hier aus den niederlanden kommen und
in diesen randbezirken wie hier in
amsterdam da fühlt man sich sicher da
ist man unter sich und hier gibt es auch
professionelle ausbildungszentren in
denen der nachwuchs an original
geldautomaten aufsprengen lernt zugriffe
wie hier in utrecht gelingen aber nur
selten die täter sind absolute profis
die äußerst sensibel auf polizeiliche
maßnahmen reagieren hier in utrecht hat
die niederländische polizei bei einer
razzia ein ausbildungszentrum ausgerufen
etliche original geldautomaten konnten
sichergestellt werden nrw innenminister
will diesen endlich trocken legen
angesichts der brutalität und der fälle
genügt eben nicht mehr nur gut zu sein
sondern wir müssen sehr gut sein es war
eigentlich pures glück dass bisher bei
den sprengungen kein mensch oder bei der
verfolgungsfahrt kein mensch gestorben
ist pures glück ich will handeln bevor
es tote gibt dh der kampf gegen alte
geldautomaten springern ist jetzt
chefsache und ihr ministerium
zentralisiert man hat eine
sonderkommission gegründet spezialisten
jagen jetzt die panzerknacker mit
modernster fahndungs technik ein vorwurf
den man aus ermittlerkreisen aber immer
wieder hört die anreize für gangster
sind zu hoch es soll unter anderem zu
viel geld in den automaten seien
außerdem ist die sicherheitstechnik
angeblich nicht auf dem neuesten stand
im schulterschluss mit den banken mit
einer guten analyse wird es uns
gemeinsam möglichkeit sein die
sicherheit der geldautomaten zu
verbessern aber in der tat die banken
sind da auch durchaus in der pflicht
genau darüber nachzudenken welche
standorte der geldautomaten sie
verwenden wie der zugang zu der geld zu
den geldautomaten besser zu sichern ist
ob man neue geldautomaten einsetzt mit
entsprechenden klebe systemen oder
werbesystem so dass das geld unbrauchbar
gemacht wird also da gibt es eine
vielzahl von bogen vorwürfe die man sich
bei der sparkasse kreis recklinghausen
nicht gefallen lassen will die
allerneueste technik haben unsere
automaten sowieso wir haben im gesamten
geschäftsgebiet keinen automaten älter
ist als drei jahre also alle automaten
sind gegen gas zum beispiel gesichert
alle automaten haben die größte
schutzklasse im tresor der in den
automaten ist das ist eine mär dass wir
zu viele automaten bestände ihn über
nacht in den tresoren halten
ende juni schlägt die polizei zeitgleich
in deutschland und den niederlanden zu
im morgengrauen schleichen
schwerbewaffnete elitepolizisten durch
ein treppenhaus im niederländischen
helmond
das spezialeinsatzkommando rammt eine
tür aufreißt mutmaßliche sprenger aus
dem schlaf diesmal knallt es an der tür
der gangster auch in nrw niedersachsen
rheinland pfalz und hessen klingelt die
polizei am frühen morgen 100 beamte
durchsuchen insgesamt 16 objekte im
visier der deutschen fahnder mitarbeiter
von autovermietern die fahrzeug
verleihen sollen den automaten springern
hoch motorisierte fluchtwagen zur
verfügung gestellt haben ob sie wussten
dann wählen sie die autos vermieteten
oder ob sie ahnungslos waren noch unklar
80 handys pcs tablets und elektronische
datenträger werden sichergestellt 35
handys finden die ermittler allein in
einem objekt in recklinghausen dazu
sogenannte demmer zum stören von
mobilfunknetzen gestohlene kennzeichen
täterkleidung unterlagen ordner monate
lang ermittelten deutsche und
niederländische beamte zusammen mit
europol verdeckt gegen 17 personen
insgesamt wurden in den niederlanden 13
mutmaßliche automaten springer
festgenommen die männer sollen in
deutschland zwölf geldautomaten in die
luft gejagt haben beute und
gebäudeschäden durch die sprengungen
mehr als vier millionen euro
das heute morgen ist ein großer schlag
gegen die geldautomaten sprenger szene
und er kommt mit sicherheit auch bei den
geldautomaten sprengungen an und genau
das wollen wir natürlich auch der um es
auf den punkt zu bringen wir müssen
genau so weitermachen wie wir das jetzt
seit zwei jahren machen der in
zusammenarbeit natürlich auch mit dem
bka und europol und den anderen partnern
in den bundesländern das wird auch nötig
sein der summe ist noch lange nicht
trockengelegt mehrere hundert springer
sind noch immer aktiv niemand ist vor
ihnen sicher keiner weiß wo sie als
nächstes zuschlagen und auch diese nacht
macht es irgendwo in deutschland
wieder boomen
[Musik]